I can't believe he had the audacity to
bring up intelligence I was like Craig
goddamn it Oh
want to punch you right in the mouth
coke you know coke look yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah oh they're on the
mountaintop guys they're bright they're
Bible - yeah behind okay where this is
like some kind of street you get off
work where are you going dude yeah
they're torte vulgar coke you're looking
at know there's people down here there's
people down this hella can smoke this
I'm in the middle of it well that's why
I died
see behind Pikachu's Michigan shot
no bad guy I just got lead lead hide
behind the rock good job folks down I
got him you got this all right I got two
kills and Craig just run well taste
banana and the peaks
we could always a bit is a Steve gonna
stream we can get dream he's probably
naked right now said I can't stream and
you get the most viewers streaming right
now see if I can come us it was a day
what's a day I don't have a lot it's
March 11 and March 11th
yeah wfe please publish hmm
March 11th we are [ __ ] eat where is
the streaming software March damn it
11 are you just gonna use twitch for now
are you gonna use that cuz what are you
gonna use that okay for now I'm a
broadcast there we go alright boys is it
did you include your audio for everyone
else Steve and let me check let me check
all right awesome
hello I'm gonna go okay
here you go yeah so how do you like
switch weapons on the menu how do you do
all that stuff in order do you do that
stuff I'll show you you just will show
you when you get in there okay cool
it's easier to show you them to like
tell you now and then oh oh that's gonna
get me cuz it's easier guys do it
[Music]
so where you been TV everything been
gone just what yeah just doing the show
sasha grey was Hamlet came over last
week I was hoping that she'd knock on
your door man but I'm good glad she came
to your show yeah people don't come to
my door they when they go see Steve here
talk about stuff Steve
[Music]
usually they think my place is like my
front door just the way you said it
though good server my stream somebody
look at my stream and make sure that
it's no air Griffin comedy okay look
said we've got an hour yeah I see it
sure I see it can you guys hear the chat
people though yeah yeah you're
broadcasting okay make sure everybody's
audio is included yeah Griffin yours is
good you can see it looking here the the
chat you got yeah
[Music]
yeah we cursed time we're all together
dude right now I Stevie gonna you gotta
start you gotta press Start I got oh I
got a start
yeah we all do just got a radio Steve
know how to play this I do not know how
to play this that's why it looks good
[Laughter]
for you guys to get the clip all right
and my thing stalled so I think we're
not I'm not doing well yeah no how do
you punch okay oh my looking clean buddy
[Laughter]
you gotta put a point down mansion
mansion right here okay just tell me
tell me when to jump press B say 1 3 2 1
you see that compass there's a yellow
Mart just go towards that okay I jumped
yeah yeah we just head towards the
yellow mark where are you guys right
below you don't see you guys I don't see
you guys it's red bus little lake it's
just the lake Stevie little puddle I'm
like wait a minute
I'm all alone dude
oh there's 800 let's [ __ ] go this is
gonna be the worst opener oh yeah yeah
there's like so many people right here
this is not gonna go well at all yeah
I'm gonna go in this first one Jesus
Christ you couldn't pick like a place
with more people this is like the worst
you're right crank in the door they're
gonna [ __ ] jump ya [ __ ] okay I got a
bullet loop I got some kind of foreign
thing well the graphics are still
rendering right now that's [ __ ] crazy
there's no goddamn [ __ ] ammo shot
that guy I'm out of ammo
okay fine I'm gonna get stuck in the
[ __ ] I'm gonna get stuck in the
stairs [ __ ] I gotta get out I dunno how
do you how do you [ __ ] in a hole to
reload I forgot got a gay guy coming at
you Craig over there yeah I know he is
and where is it Lizzie okay I got a
shotgun guys [ __ ] I need help it's in
here all running around please vest
honey how did he kill you oh [ __ ] so
much coming I hear somebody put on viga
oh my god who's this person that's
somebody I know that one of my people I
got one down oh [ __ ] I'm some guy in
here I just shot him oh my god he's
trying to come in my door
kill him Griffin kill him oh my god ah
this guy got me [ __ ] oh he had that
heavy machine gun [ __ ] yeah
not beating that well Steve left the
party his said his stream went offline
oh okay
well I'm now oh [ __ ] somebody just open
my door oh it says Griffin's playing Pac
Man on Twitch you could jump out the
window man I'm not playing Pac Man what
that's what this is up to it just says
you're playing Pac Man people are in
Cheddar like whoa Patman got sick you oh
god I was a mistake have you changed
that okay he's I think he got
disconnected from the chat yeah
oh boy in the game and he's out the
party that's not right I guess
Steve's not coming back boys I'm sorry
I'm sorry stream what am i doing on what
is why didn't say Pat on this I guess
can I put it's a game so I put pub G and
it didn't you know I mean you put it
under another category Craig can you see
what's up with Steve okay I guess I got
to put the whole name of the game
Battlefront
no it's not Battlefront what's this game
called player pub battlegrounds you got
to type in player unknown ya dig
hmm up there Steve he's dead okay there
it is I changed it
it's Walmart Wi-Fi all right so now I
gotta get out of here exit to lobby
right hey try and get Steve back in here
and then try and teach him how to play
the game the game is not that hard to
play really peek at you again yeah I
gotta get surgery on my nose you got too
excited
Mathers damn did they have an internet
shortage in their [ __ ] area or
something
[Music]
wait how come there's only me a coconut
if they yeah I think there's some in it
there's some internet issues going on
with those guys
os is the server will be in maintenance
from 1:00 a.m. Pacific time in
preparation for the new patch it will
take 30 minutes
well that's about to happen right now
right now yeah Craig just texted me he's
hoping Steve fix it game and update your
client apologies for the inconvenience
the servers will be a maintenance from
one a m-- pacific time 10:00 a.m. that's
fine cuz just jump right in and banner
Matt yeah do a quick one before they
jump on ya I don't know but they might
not get back on I think we got it
we have an outage area because we both
got kicked out keep trying
I blink where it's always Christ fault
always Craig's fault yeah he's the
father
can't believe he had the audacity to
bring up intelligence I was like Craig
goddamn it nope
want to punch you right in the mouth
Toki you know I'll cook look yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it's on straight
no I'm pumped for the patch though
because I it's gonna crucible is gonna
be way more fun it's going to be like
destiny one just check out hound ish on
YouTube and you'll see all the updates
look good but you know what I think I'm
gonna get Griffin I think my division
two when that comes out oh they're gonna
be division oh yeah this is dope man so
the first was dope
you know she says they're not getting
back on he called Time Warner and
they're doing work on it and they're not
gonna have it till 6:00 in the morning
oh wow for real Craig not a joke
liar liar okay
oh you can't get along okay no no we'll
miss you okay support Arkady but my KT
is gonna go okay oh then we have more
boarded one pump gee and one network all
right let me focus let me wake up let's
do this
once yes
stole my rocket pod ready yeah that's
[ __ ] and he was going fast whoa far2
your rocket pulled ahead onto the side
what's our Pharma oh my god this
invisibility [ __ ] man Wagner I set him
up Nick Pope takes him down man that's
the second one
here we go again everybody it's right
there evidence right on the screen -
finally oh [ __ ] watch out slow look at
my character smiles [ __ ]
it's a Titan in the Dark Age week oh
yeah call anytime I'm not riding
backside cope whoa
oh nice job boys good job boys good job
you mean regulars
yeah we call him Steve okay finally
gotta kill 13 sharpies we're moving fast
[ __ ] em up
this morning
well I got to see what it is now you
guys are going so fast looking night
stalkers hey they're gonna get heavy
seven five I got this one five minutes
remain five minutes for me
there he uses them oh man
look I'm shooting my gun dude like frame
rate or something it doesn't seem on my
screen I'm shooting the guy I'm kidding
perhaps what yes got his ass
lingering flame a Titan lingering flame
buddy that's the one all these invisible
[ __ ] man but you could see them whether
you can't do anything that's what
they're changing because the aim-assist
they're adding it's run by hunters just
cloaking all over
what what tell me oh my god why isn't my
guy says I got to change my [ __ ]
something's going on my mobility I
didn't die you [ __ ] this what I'm saying
keep getting away from with a sliver of
HP Chevy's coming they're coming back I
just got some kind of milestone though
three minutes yeah oh my god kill him
look at you
thank you he's dead yeah by time I get
anywhere you guys killed him already
oh I got him on the side yep there we go
- one enough little [ __ ] base
oh my god
good team shot good [ __ ] there we go
[ __ ] yeah I don't even care if it's for
v3 there all night stalkers heavy I'll
hiding back there honey
Heather [ __ ] damn Pikachu so these must
I'm not using my [ __ ] super because I
get my grenade faster oh my super is
charged and this grenades beast don't
please screw date behind behind mine I
know I see him right here I was hurt
they're right here
oh he stole my kill again good I'm glad
we got that on I did not exact I don't
care that's perfect I was in front of
him I wasn't serve you I don't know how
you stole they kill what at least you
saved me this time at least I didn't die
this time that usually pisses me off no
I'm giving you credit I just gave you
credit this time you did it right I you
you saved me instead of like coming in
and I died there you kill him that's
usually your move
that's the original car let's just move
it's like you shoot him they kill you
and he comes in and cleans up
[ __ ] I had an arc soul and my hammers
Wow
20:29 baby it's gonna be used you ever
battled like an old friend
nice KD okay thanks 1:8 very good there
you go yeah we got that on the record
it's better than Craig
we all win positive well I got Craig so
heated because I was talking about
people's KDS and I was like Griffin's
got a better KD than you do and Steve's
got a better KD in here he goes yeah but
look at how many games they played they
don't play as many games I told them I'm
like it's truly impressive when you're
kad
which just kills assists and essa
counselor sis is still negative
like everybody under positive mind
spiral positive but he's negative
it's called by just side on what's
called the travelers judgement yeah that
thing's beast dude it's really good
using a submachine gun but I just don't
I'm not a good close quarters a they
were saying some of the new some of the
pulse rifles are gonna be really good in
an update literally buffing it or
something there while they're buffing
that pulse rifles pulse rifles
okay nice my nightshade why darkness
before okay let's just keep doing that
like I thought we were already
broadcasting mind of mine was [ __ ]
out for a second but I had to refresh
and I did I think which sucks man i
conned them on the xbox but when you use
it like on any of these apps yeah what's
a lot better yeah yeah oh it's going now
would you say pika it's not can you
check if cooks streaming cuz I'm
refreshing my thing and it doesn't show
I'm streaming though right you're
getting money yeah you're working yeah
mommy open the chat oh I see it's
working
yeah we're not gonna stay up late mom oh
my god thirsty still trying to call mom
Griffin and Coke say hi I can provide a
lot more than Craig just let her know
okay read Craig's and belay you want
some red vines Craig will be like but
cokes just an ass hold of women he
doesn't like he's not nice I can't
believe that's what
I hate this map
iron banner class gunner class you have
any boons
all right let's do this boys
[ __ ] alright sorry I'm back I forgot
Shh
well heavy comes quick man like yeah
there's somebody there the dictionary
yeah just for iron banner walked out the
Titan pack yes
Oh Pikachu stole my kill but I got the
assist as well min first oh you guys got
the kill
whoa rock me to oblivion going
nice good teacher yeah
ah all the way back I gotta get this new
Auto rifle madness I'm really fun
yeah thanks good good what is it doc
yeah it's an iron banner one and it's a
primary it's good and then just like
your secondary as a long-range gun in
the Dark Age we call this a scout rifle
on I'm going scout rifle sidearm baby oh
[ __ ] heavy
they got heavy oh they're all ours on
their team careful oh man
positive freaking out look I'm switchin
coming to you Otto Otto back off I was
Wisconsin Griffin it was actually pretty
good
got him oh [ __ ] did you record your
special there or were you recording your
specials no in Portland on the 47 it
yeah weird weird weird Tuesday night
what's the venue's it like a theater or
something yeah nice to the left to left
there's too much how did that guy
survive that oh my god ah he's so rich I
don't buy that oh my god that's so
ridiculous this guy just had a miracle
survival oh I just walked in on three of
them that was my fault thank you for the
pitch them could swing me neither
got it I got heavy dude he's super
lagging one of these guys yeah yeah he
keeps moving in and out yeah like it's
like e strafing it's a Titan
nice good [ __ ] Griffin that guy he's the
richer how do you smell the [ __ ]
survived that he's glitching your legs
switching or something Charlie my god
dude
Charlie unbelievable on frickin
believable thank you it's my birthday
right now by the way Oh March baby my
little birthday destiny everywhere
report them oh how did he kiss still get
me behind my shield
Stevie's the heavies about to come got
it all this heavies in a weird spot Oh
somebody got did you guys get that okay
hey they got a Bolognese or maybe they
have a ball in the mantle calling you I
got to oldy three minutes hit that guy
bottom blue team shot that little [ __ ]
[ __ ] Titan [ __ ] that Titan nice the
glitchy slams the other one give am
bottom huh
what's a storm plus four guys watch out
we got them yeah hey stop seen the F
word okay sorry hey-ho oh my god how did
they survive that always so fun stare oh
my God he's so hurt
he's like a sliver arc arc sterile I got
him I got him tethered back there oh
nice dinner oh my god dude he just did
it everybody saw that on Twitch yeah we
love all these twitch witnesses oh [ __ ]
your sword yeah [ __ ] him up that was
team this is team City
oh my god mmm finish this stick together
yeah mob together boys slam oh we got
him we got him
that's what I'm saying just stick
together one more one more we got it got
him yeah oh my god I died we I think we
should go to the tower for a second and
my pickup attempt Rises running go to
the tower last time trash banana don't
ever come here don't ever compare me to
green I know it was low no I'm not
hiding in the corner waiting for the
heavy disappear put up a shield you know
I tell you rules
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]